antoine chédid merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france où étiez vous
quand l'explosion a eu lieu
bonjour moi j'étais dans une autre ville
côtière qui s'appelle byblos et qui se
trouve à peu près à 40 km de beyrouth
mais on a entendu l'explosion et on a
ressenti l'ondé de choc qui a qui est
arrivé jusqu'à nous et quelle est la
situation sur place
à l'heure actuelle est ce que vous en
savez plus à la situation est
catastrophique le liban vit une
catastrophe humaine urbaine sans
précédent comme vous avez montré dans
votre sujet c'est une scène de guerre
sans guerre beyrouth est dévastée
beyrouth et martyrs et bailleurs ont été
blessées de centaines de victimes de
martyrs de victimes innocentes des
milliers de blessés
les hôpitaux hier était saturé ne
pouvait plus accueillir les blessés et
ont plus trois de ces hôpitaux qui se
trouvent dans dans la zone de la
déflagration
on était hors service immédiatement
parce que l'électricité l'eau et
l'oxygène ont été coupés et ses hôpitaux
étaient obligés de transférer leurs
malades hospitalisés d'une façon
chronique dans les hôpitaux
d'autres villes du liban et de soigner
les blessés qui affluent et par
centaines dans des couloirs et voir à
l'extérieur des hôpitaux
alors au vu de la situation dramatique
un l'aide internationale est vital pour
beyrouth
elle est en train d'arriver est ce que
c'est un petit peu un soulagement
bien sûr le liban tout seul ne pourra
pas faire face à cette catastrophe
humaine et urbaine
il est qu'il ait des gens dans une dans
une situation très difficile
le pays est dans une situation dans une
crise économique dans une crise
financière et une crise sanitaire liée
aux coronavirus et les gens ont les
libanais sont en difficulté l'état est
presque en faillite et donc le liban ne
pourra pas se relever
sans l'aide de la communauté
internationale et sans l'aide des états
unis qui comme vous avez dit dans votre
sujet ont commencé à envoyer l'aide
humanitaire qu'on a besoin immédiatement
pour continuer à soigner les blessés et
par la suite reconstruire et réparer
tous ces dégâts matériels qui sont
partout dans la capitale
alors le premier ministre hassan diab a
promis que les responsables devraient
rendre des comptes
c'est l'heure du deuil bien sûr mais
selon vous est-ce que des erreurs ont
été commises et bien celle enquête qui
doit déterminer qui sont les
responsables et s'il ya eu des erreurs
mais comment on peut comprendre c'est
inadmissible qu'il y ait dans un port à
proximité d'une ville comme beyrouth des
tonnes d'explosifs si puissant si
dévastateur bien sûr il faut que les
coupables que les responsables de de ce
crime contre le liban soit jugé et ils
soient traduits devant la justice
alors vous parliez à des dégâts
matériels un la perte est estimée en
tout cas en ce moment à 3 milliards de
dollars il y aurait également trois cent
mille libanais à l'heure actuelle sans
domicile fixe le liban qu'aider à un
pays au bord du gouffre actuellement
comment va-t-il faire quel levier
actionné pour s'en remettre
vous savez les libanais sont des
résistants ils sont vaccinés contre ces
problèmes le liban toujours comme le
phénix renaîtra de ses cendres
on va s'organiser la saulaie solidarité
internationale va se mettre en place
la solidarité de la diaspora libanaise
qui partout dans le monde va s'organiser
pour venir en aide à leur pays à leur
pays d'origine au liban aux libanais et
bien sûr avec l'aide de la communauté
internationale et des pays amis
on va reconstruire beyrouth quitte à
petit la maintenant de l'urgence c'est
de reloger les les personnes qui ne sont
qu' non plus
maison com vous avez dit qu'ils sont
sans eau sans électricité et qui n'ont
plus de fenêtres parce que si les
immeubles sont toujours debout dans
certains quartiers il n'y a plus de
porte plus de fenêtres plus rien à
l'intérieur de leur appartement
donc toute cette personne là sont
hébergés ailleurs dans d autres villes
beaucoup de foyers beaucoup d'églises
beaucoup de nos d'associations et doit
mg ont ouvert leurs portes pour
accueillir ces gens qui n'ont plus de
place pour pour y rester alors
politiquement est-ce que ce drame va
affaiblir le président et son
gouvernement des gens rappelle très
contesté par les libanais ou alors au
contraire favoriser une sorte d'union
nationale face à ce drame
vous savez au delà des clivages
politiques c'est maintenant l'union
nationale on est face à une catastrophe
sans ampleur tous les libanais doivent
être soudés autour de leur état autour
de leur gouvernement
autour de leur président pour faire face
pour faire face à cette catastrophe sans
précédent
je pense que c'est pas le moment
maintenant de faire la politique
politicienne et tous les responsables
politiques que l'on compris pour le
moment il faut aider les libanais à
supporter cette catastrophe humaine et
urbaine et en urgence apporter de l'aide
à tous ceux qui en ont besoin
antoine chédid merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
à l'ancien coordinateur du cpl en france
le courant patriotique libre le parti du
président michel aoun merci